-Hey, everybody.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show:
At-Home Edition."
My name is Jimmy Fallon.
This is Franny Fallon.
This is Winnie Fallon,
and my wife is
the camera operator today.
Guys, we are --
April 15th, today is, Wednesday,
and hopefully you're
doing your part
and staying at home like we are.
If you are going out,
make sure to wear a mask, right?
And if you -- If you don't
have a mask, you can make one.
There's a lot of things online.
You can learn how to do it.
I saw a cool thing.
Matthew McConaughey
used a bandanna
and put a coffee filter
in the bandana
and used that to make
a face mask with rubber bands.
That's pretty cool, right?
We have a big show today.
Pharrell Williams
is on the show,
very talented Pharrell Williams.
We love him.
Also, his charity is
World Central Kitchen,
wck.org.
He's doing stuff
with José Andrés.
That's a picture
of a dinosaur, right?
Or is that a duck?
-Dinosaur.
-Oh, okay.
-[ Chuckles ]
-And then we have
Millie Bobby Brown,
who we love,
and her charity is unicef.org.
Speaking of charities,
by the way,
a lot of people
have been stepping up,
and I think it's a great thing,
so thank you, everyone,
for donating.
And my family's donating
to every charity
that we mention on our show,
but our friends over at T-Mobile
wanted to do something
really cool.
If you text "THANKS" to 50555,
they're going to --
You'll donate $5 to the Boys
and Girls Club of America.
Right now, they have a COVID-19
relief fund for front-line --
people working on the front line
for childcare for them,
'cause they're working
all the time.
-Are you doing this one, Winnie?
-Yeah, are you?
-No, I'm doing
the princess, though.
-And, so, anyways, these people
have to take care of their kids,
so this will help.
So, if you go to your phone,
I'm using my phone to film,
but if you go to your phone
and text "THANKS" to 50555,
T-Mobile said they will match
up to $400,000
in the next three days.
That's a lot of money.
So that's today,
tomorrow, and Friday,
if you text "THANKS" to 50555
they will automatically
bill you $5.
Right?
And there you go.
Did you draw this?
No. Winnie, did you draw this?
-Yes. So, yeah.
-Who is it?
-It's two of my classmates.
-I thought it was me and Mommy.
-No.
They're both girls.
They can't be.
-Well, this one's --
Which -- Who's this one?
-One that Mommy knows.
-Oh, okay.
I thought it was Daddy
and Mommy, and I thought...
-Amara.
-...Daddy had, like,
a little cloud over his head
or something.
-Amara.
-Yeah, that's Amara.
-That's Amara.
-Oh, okay, that's Amara.
-That's Audrey.
-Okay, good. It's your friends.
Okay. So this is not
me or your mom.
I thought you loved me so much,
I thought maybe you'd draw
a nice picture of me,
but what are you going to do?
Okay, guys.
It is time for monologue.
Can you guys clap?
You guys like monologue?
-Unh-unh.
-Here we go.
-[ Blows raspberry ]
-Welcome to "The Tonight Show:
At-Home Edition."
Well, guys, today was
supposed to be Tax Day,
but it was all postponed
until July 15th.
The kids are excited
'cause now we get to leave all
of our Tax Day decorations up
for another three months.
Who wants to light
the W-2 forms?
I do. I do.
[ Chuckles ]
Tax Day is now
after the 4th of July
which means a lot of Americans
will be able to claim
their fingers and eyebrows
as a total loss.
Some 2020 news --
It was a big day for Joe Biden
as he picked up an endorsement
from Elizabeth Warren.
In the past few days, Biden's
been endorsed by Bernie Sanders,
President Obama,
and Elizabeth Warren
while Trump just laughed
and said,
"But look who's got
the MyPillow guy."
I saw that Sony and PlayStation
have started
the Play at Home initiative
to encourage gamers
to stay indoors.
Yeah, that's always been
the problem with gamers --
They spend
too much time outside.
I saw the State of New Jersey
is holding a benefit show
called Jersey for Jersey.
It's the only benefit show
where the host threatens you
with a baseball bat.
[ Chuckles ]
It's the only benefit show
where you send a donation,
and they say, "Eh."
-[ Blows raspberry ]
-They say, "Eh, feels light."
The envelope feels light.
I read that a lot of colleges
are starting to think
that classes won't be in person
this fall.
It's awkward when you do your
fraternity initiation over Zoom,
and you have to ask your dad to
smack your butt with a paddle.
[ Chuckles ]
Yeah, that's right,
'cause of the virus,
kids applying
to college this fall
might not have to submit
S.A.T. scores.
In response, Lori Loughlin
texted Felicity Huffman,
"You've got to be F'ing
kidding me."
Here's some news
for "Jeopardy!" fans.
I saw that -- Sorry.
-Mm-hmm.
-Here's some news
for "Jeopardy!" fans.
I saw that Alex Trebek
is releasing a memoir.
Meanwhile, if you like "Wheel of
Fortune," Pat Sajak is releasing
one of those books
that float in the bathtub.
[ Chuckles ]
And finally --
Oh.
Here's the cover
of the "Wheel of Fortune" book.
Finally, I saw that many people
are actually getting dumped
via Zoom, and it's created
the term "getting Zumped."
Don't confuse that with a Zump,
when is when you forget
your camera's on
when you take your phone
into the bathroom.
That's our monologue, everybody.
Yahoo!
Now we're going to do our thing
that we've been doing
every Wednesday
where I look through
the Internet and try to find
fun things that people are doing
while being quarantined.
It is called,
"What Are You Doing Wednesday."
♪♪
I just want to show everyone
what you did
to "The Incredibles."
You took all their clothes off.
The naked Incredibles.
Where's his clothes?
-[ Giggles ]
[ Giggles ]
-Alright. Take
"The Incredibles." Go play.
Guys, this is called
"What Are You Doing Wednesday."
Here's our first one here.
This one's really funny, guys.
This is from
@parmesan-underscore-official.
They got bored in quarantine,
so she decided to do
the apple fork challenge
where you throw an apple,
and you catch it on a fork,
and she did it like three times.
Watch.
-Yes.
Yes.
Yes!
-Yes.
-Yes!
-[ Laughs ]
That was really funny, right?
The next one is called
Car Door Ride.
This one is from
@rachel.thomas91.
She caught her son taking an
unexpected ride in the driveway.
Watch this kid.
[ Wagner's "Ride
of the Valkyries" playing ]
♪♪
Watch, he starts flying.
[ Wagner's "Ride
of the Valkyries" playing ]
He's holding on to the --
The thing picks him up
in the air.
[ Laughs ]
-I like the other one more.
-Yeah.
-Me, too.
-Well, I thought
that was pretty good.
He looked like Jack-Jack.
Now do you like it?
I thought it was funny.
Our last one here is called
Megaphone Neighbor.
This one is from @gracecuratolo.
Her neighbor gave an impassioned
speech to her block.
Take a look at this.
-I just want you to know
that I miss you and I love you!
Can't wait for this [bleep] show
to be over
so that I can touch people,
drink with people,
and have the best life ever!
-Miss you, too, Tracy!
-Very nice!
Nice use of that megaphone
right there.
Guys, I got my wife's phone,
so I'm actually going
to do this, text "THANKS"
to 50555.
T-Mobile's helping
with the Girls and Boys Club.
50555,
and all you do
is you text "THANKS."
"To complete your $5 donation
to Boys and Girls Club,
reply with your five-digit
billing ZIP Code."
I lost Franny. Alright.
I'm going to say my ZIP Code.
"Thanks. $5 charged
to phone bill."
Perfect. It works.
Guys, we'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show."
Come on back.